a former emergency room doctor
screenwriter Masson sagai one an a
double acp Image Award for bail she made
her writing debut on the secret laughter
of women and adapted Zora Neale
Hurston's Their Eyes Were Watching God
presenting the award to vigil Jame is
Miss answer guy
[Applause]
good evening we've spoken a lot about
what makes her Nichols fellowship
finalist I think you might as well ask
what makes a writer what do we look for
there's talent and an authentic voice
and I can't deny my pride in having this
Nigerian subject dealt with by a
Nigerian writer
there's craft there's practice and
there's experience but what sets these
scripts apart for me is courage the
courage of a writer from the outset we
write as a subject to so much received
wisdom being told what kinds of stories
sell what characters we need to make it
watchable what kind of actors will be
cast in order to make the script
bankable what will sell overseas over
and over again we are invited to limit
ourselves with this received wisdom it
takes a writer to say no to listen to
the received wisdom with respect and yet
in the end go your own way because this
is the story you want to tell vigil Chi
Mei is courageous because she did just
that born in Nigeria her parents
emigrated to the United States where and
she was brought up in use in Houston
living in New York she now works as a
schoolteacher conventional wisdom says
that all of us want to send our children
here to school after all there are
people who want to build walls to keep
us out there are so many of us and yet
vigil sent her son from New York back to
Nigeria to school I asked her why
he said I wanted a place for him where a
black boy is seen as a king her script
bring back girl
also surprised me every time this script
came to a fork in the road
it didn't just take the road less
traveled it left the road altogether
that made its way across country I
honestly didn't know where it would end
up but I was never lost never afraid
because vigil is a great storyteller
she's always in command of her narrative
always in command of her characters her
heroine is a chibok girl but vigil took
the courageous decision to make her one
who got away
and at first I wasn't sure about this
she's then trafficked as a child bride
and then the script becomes a
rip-roaring action story of a father
looking for his daughter but at last I
understand the importance of the courage
and the authentic voice because in
telling the story of the girl that got
away
she ends up telling us everything about
the girls that are still missing
they have no greater advocate an African
writer a beautiful script a courageous
writer my countryman vigil Chima
[Applause]
good evening
do I sound calm I'm not at all to make
matters worse I'm standing not next to
one celebrity but four Wow well I'm
gonna try not to embarrass myself or my
country I begin my thanks to miss a gay
herself indeed it is a greatest thrill
as a Nigerian to be introduced by
another Nigerian British though she may
be what are the odds thank you so much
for all those beautiful things you said
about me I mean I didn't recognize
myself at all but I would try and see
myself through your eyes a little story
about my involvement with the nickel in
2008 I had written what I thought was a
masterpiece it had power it had courage
it had all those things I thought
anybody would read it and see the
meaning of life in what I was trying to
do they didn't agree at all
he didn't even didn't even get to
quarterfinals the rejection was so
painful that I swore that said I'm done
with the nickel I'm never going to talk
to them ever again it was like a bad
breakup you know if you break up with a
guy you swear off guys for all eternity
I've moved on with my life and I mean
that was 2008 so fast forward to 2017
bring back girl is ready you know and I
it was a very simple story compared to
the one I wrote in 2008 it was simple
because I was gonna go off to Africa
immediately and shoot her but I got into
a small snag I wasn't able to raise the
funds to actually begin or even complete
the story in frustration I went knocking
on an old boyfriends door the nickel I
said well here I am back again I know I
swore but I can't just leave her sitting
there so I turned it in I promptly
forgot that I did
and I just I mean why not I mean you've
built a very tough skin of rejection
there's they can do nothing to me at
this point
so imagine imagine my shock and awe when
I started getting the notification this
script is really good they said
quarterfinals I said really
okay bye semifinal seriously I actually
went back and read the script to be sure
what are they talking about like really
this one and then lo and behold you know
I could not have anticipated that we
would be here tonight I could not have
anticipated that I would win I could not
have anticipated all that when he would
bring I mean I have people calling me
speaking to me as if I have a writing
career and nor could I have foreseen
that my words those words are being
spoken by mr. Vaughn by Miss embosser ah
by mr. Santoro and by mr. Shay had I
known that my words would come out of
your mouths literally I would have
agonized more with the dialogue I would
have struggled to make them more
profound and eloquent but as to that
there was no need you guys read so
beautifully I mean I I was transported
out of this vast room to the AMC theater
in Harlem where I watched my movies
thank you so much for taking the time
out of your very busy lives to honor us
with your craft now I want to give a
gratitude to my family there are three
in the audience my brother Ken who
bought a a new outfit for this evening I
call this guy all the time what do you
think would happen here what do you know
don't do that do not do that so he's my
story guru my son here 16 year old judo
be he is my true work-in-progress when
he learned that mom won he's like I knew
you would this is your year you've been
riding since I was born which is true
but he later I figured out why he was
saying that he asked me so how much of
the prize do I get
you forget that your entire room and
board for life you owe me bro my my
auntie is here from Connecticut
she let me tell you what this woman did
upon learning that I I had won she took
it upon herself to call family she said
our vigil has won a very important award
and they said what kind of award she
said he's so important it's like she won
the Oscar ah the person screamed and
called somebody else substituted the
word like the Oscar for our vigil has
been nominated for an Oscar that person
screamed even louder I picked up the
phone and called a third person and now
said our vigil has won the Oscar in
screenwriting all over the world and in
the village all the Chima is roared even
those I'm not related to family and I
have street cred you know because of
this award so I am so thrilled in the
audience I want to say it I have some
supporters these are women screenwriters
over 40 yes I know I don't look it but I
am actually a woman screenwriter over 40
I met these ladies at the writers lab
retreat not too long ago ladies you're
in the house please let's make some
noise this is our moment so I win this
award not just for me but for all of us
but I will keep the money thank you
and finally finally the greatest thanks
I reserve to the Academy I mean I have
to I can't leave the stage without
saying thank you to the Academy to Don
and Gina Co who saw the need and the
vision to create this fellowship in 1986
85 to the army of readers who were able
to indeed with all seven thousand
entries into ten to the committee that
did have a spirited from what I hear
discussion to choose from that ten to
five they put this entire week together
and this evening and that's not all
consider that they paid for my flight
from New York to here consider that they
put me in a plush hotel on Beverly Hills
considering that they gave me a stipend
to cover the expenses for this week and
this is not to mention the prize itself
through it all the team has been
exceptional in their support I mean
they're asking me is it vigil or vigil
is it chime or team a is it bubucaca or
bubucaca I mean who does this who does
this people who want to make sure that
this evening goes well you are the
greatest champion and committee of
writers anywhere and in short tonight
this entire experience has made me feel
truly as if I did win the Oscar so thank
you thank you